When we first learn about the cells
due to the images we see
in textbooks or even in some micro-pictures
under a microscope
imagine the cells as small bubbles
with a liquid around which various things swim.
This here
is a common image in textbooks
cross-section of a cell,
in which we see all its important parts.
We can see the kernel.
We also see the endoplasmic network.
Like the Golgi Apparatus.
Here is the mitochondria.
In the way it is painted,
they seem to swim in an intracellular fluid.
They seem to swim in the intracellular fluid.
It is true that the cage contains plenty of water.
Even our bodies consist mainly of water.
A large amount of that water contained in you is in the cage.
It turns out that in these types of drawings
is missing a very important part of the structure of the cell.
There is no intracellular fluid.
Intracellular fluid.
This is still something,
which we are trying to understand better. How the intracellular fluid works
and how it helps
the cell, its structure, and how things are moving
and shapes them.
"Cytoskeleton" is one word,
but I have written the different parts of the word
with different colors, because the word itself literally means
"Cell skeleton".
If I try to actually represent
this intracellular fluid
I will have all these structures.
I will use another color.
I have all these structures that cross the cell,
in different ways that have proteins,
related issues. They move
and grow, and so can
to help the cell move or help through
transferring things inside the cage.
and other things to attach to them.
That is why it is very, very, very much
more complicated than that,
which is depicted in this drawing.
before I have the opportunity to write on top of it.
To help us imagine it,
I found this picture.
Here's a photo for public.
I find it charming because it really helps
to understand the complexity,
which undergoes even one of the cells in your body.
So let's look at some of the structures here.
This thing I'm following here,
is called microfilament.
This is a microfilament.
Let me write it down.
So here's a microfilament.
Just to get an idea of ​​its scale,
its diameter - that diameter
is about 6 or 7 nm.
So, approximately 6 or 7 nm
6 or 7 billion per meter.
To gain some insight into how this looks,
when referring to the cell,
the regular cell may be 6 to 7 μm
of diameter, even more.
This is essentially one thousandth
of the cell diameter.
What I draw here,
actually does not go so far in scale.
Even, maybe I would like to paint it even thinner.
So you will not see her often
in these diagrams because you will have to draw it very thinly.
The diameter of one of these filaments is approximately,
of the order
of one thousandth of the diameter of an ordinary cell.
These things, however, are extremely important.
They help build a cell structure.
They are made of actin proteins.
You can see
there are such two actins,
you can imagine them as ropes,
wrapped around each other.
The protein involved here.
Let me change the color.
I use it too often.
The protein found in microfilaments is actin.
It's actin.
What is important about these microfilaments is,
that in the cage, as I have already mentioned,
help build a structure.
They help in doing many things.
In fact, they can be dynamic,
somewhat destroyed and built.
Their lengths can change.
This can help the cell move and even more -
you can use them.
You can carry things between them.
You can pull them.
There is a fascinating interaction
between the actin and what you see here.
This is it
made from myosin.
This is myosin.
Let me write it.
It's hard to see.
This is myosin.
The link to the actin is that myosin
plays the role of something that shoots myosin.
They can move together.
This is important for muscle contraction.
It is remarkable to see,
that even the proteins,
which are composed of a bunch of amino acids,
can interact in these relatively complex ways
and that you can have these myosines,
who hit and move the actin.
This is myosin here.
We see ribosomes.
These ribosomes are the same ribosomes,
which are not attached to the endoplasmic network.
Here are free ribosomes.
So, you see how complicated it is.
You can say, "Okay
I see these microfilaments made of actin.
I see one I have emphasized.
There are others here.
I see another one there.
I see one here too.
What, however, are these large, pipe-like structures,
which we also see?
For example,
what is this?
What are these trumpet-like structures?
Well they are called microtubules.
And so - microtubules.
They look enormous compared to microfilaments.
However, they are relatively small on the cellular scale.
The microtubule is about 25 nm.
Again, they play an important role
in the cell structure.
They allow some things to be arranged
and some things to be carried.
They are also dynamic particles of the cell.
They can be both built and destroyed.
They can also form the cell itself.
In animal cells -
the things I have described can be found in most cells,
but in animal cells
you will also find things called intermedia filaments.
In size are located midway between these two,
which also helps maintain form and other things.
The purpose of this video
is to make you appreciate more things.
Maybe all the other videos we have about the cage,
make you appreciate what beauty
and what complexity they have,
which very often in everyday life
we consider it as ordinary as a cage.
There are so many aspects of the beauty and complexity of the structure and,
that it is often not described
in the drawings of the cell,
which you can find in your text books.
To appreciate it more
Here are some publicly available images,
which I found on cells you can see
colored cytoskeleton.
What you see in the picture,
in yellow-green color,
in fact, are cow lungs
these yellow-green lines you see,
are microtubules.
And what you see in a pink or orange color
are microfilaments.
So you can appreciate how complex it is
these things are structured,
which you looked like big spots.